[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so what you're doing is you're gonna
bring this foot over that's it
gorgeous and now you're turning around
this way and you're looking back at me
you're loving me giggling Ave that's it
beautiful gorgeous just to think fingers
together that's it
and then just bend it up a little bit
relax if he likes yeah beautiful
let me show ya maybe perfect that's all
look at me look at my city bring it a
bit more la there you go that's it and
there your chin is up yes
all right God is to be hurt turn your
body that way now twist it that's up
there gorgeous what I want you to do now
is this toe bring it out of it for me
like this
yeah like that and then shift your booty
away from me that's it Chavez back arch
your back here and they art in your face
this way a bit more beautiful all right
gorgeous that move I'll do this for you
[Music]
without moving anything darling just
your eyes back at me
[Music]
we have a smile from a gorgeous
[Music]
move forward chin up and you're laughing
that way there we go eyes more this my
eyes want my hand is to the my hand
there we go that's it perfect
put it on the head is laying roll
forward chin up and a big mouth but it's
like hahaha
there we go fantastic
all right watch your back again lean
more forward that's gorgeous 20 faces
fight chin down eyes at me beautiful
now eyes right down to the ground chin
down eyes down to the ground right with
your feet up with your feet
chin up a B though beautiful
[Music]
you spray it on your wrist and then stop
so spray it and then pause
gorgeous-looking I'm not seeing your
face here so you can get air you want in
face
[Applause]
shoulders back what can I move now
dammit
that's beautiful shot of that gorgeous
perfectly
this hand here and this hand here mm-hmm
and it and the hand here now do me
favorite scene you brought that way oh I
should do the other way now that's
better
lean forward and bring this foot forward
like this gorgeous
[Music]
Shindo face this way bit more eyes back
at me beautiful holiday
all right giggling that way giggling
that way that's gorgeous loving that
[Music]
bring your shoulder up and then chin to
the shoulder giggling and looking down
that's perfect
[Music]
come back hold your dress with both
hands like the veil Padme the veil is
that's it now turn your face extreme
this way all the way around that's it
and then bend your elbows a little bit
then your whole bug that way he likes
that's it let's go just slightly bent
okay go you know probably dying you
remember when you were Caitlin you
didn't like something it was like the
whole world was crashing down on you all
right gorgeous anybody started towards
me that's it gorgeous chin up a little
bit for me sweetie
[Music]
she enough darling gorgeous loving me
there you go
[Music]
I do a bit of a reveal he of the bride
and that as well
second this way they walk towards me
okay all right yeah sorry well but I
didn't want you to look at that way okay
give me a sec guys give me a second
there guys guys got closer good close so
you can you can
[Music]
whatever what you do don't use that
bring your head right back and you're
giggling that's a fair testing
fantastic now very very citing the count
of three what's your turning to each
other and do it comes natural you ready
one two three go for it
[Music]
[Music]
you guys cuddle up all right let's get
dead just here no that's good
honestly that's fine he's good other
files there and a little pinky there so
it's there I'm right mom I'm wrong
that's it and send your bodies in
tomorrow got tears on I can hide this
thank you so much oh I'll send you our
methods ten your body enzyme um like
this sir bit more now close the gap and
then dead I want you're just holding
here if you can and then squeeze your
face is wrongly really question guys
lean forward and lead to get I want
faces touching so we're nice and
intimate so your forehead just here
that's perfect guys alright gorgeous
[Music]
and now you're looking into deads that's
looking into you and moms looking at
that there as well we'll kick it up
[Music]
there clear it's sucking with dead and
you're turning into each other and mom I
know this sounds funny but I want you to
smile on her cheek
good good clothes go closer there we go
get rid of a kiss giggling we're loving
each other
before you leave I won't do a whole
family shot so dad over here for me
and bring your shot doing gorgeous and
then bring your hammer and mum and then
hold me you were holding before just
like this and then hold the flowers
together
okay guys lean forward lean together
touching touching intimate the user for
and then just a really close by taking
mum come back a bit more
that's it took the hit more this way and
lean more forward towards me mum that's
better
and now and this perfect guys looking at
me big smile for me nice and happy dad
just kind of touch more closer to me
beyond er here there you go that's much
better
[Music]
yeah YouTube ladies are looking at each
other but but four hits touching and
then forward touching with dad I know so
basically so what you're doing is you're
tucking it into it each other not
acknowledging Lee it feels funny but it
looks really cute so come closer to me
don't come closer to me and for it's
touching and for it's touching here with
dad yeah
for it touching and then you're giggling
into each other but you're but at the
same time writing inspection unit you
know know you're into each other into
each other the aura giggling mommy
looking right into this way have you
shown the packet giggling that's
gorgeous
let's get dad in for a shot on his own
so I'm round dad perfect and I'm around
the bride holding here the flowers and
hiding the hand behind house it got
that's it and Blaine caught towards dad
and they took ed sit now lean towards me
guys
there you go close a gap guys and
looking at me beautiful very nice
[Music]
bring your forehead on dead chick and
while you had laughing into him and then
dad's looking at his other daughter
there giggling a little why a little bit
[Laughter]
let's get mum okay close the gap
actually what we'll actually all say
there that's fine
perfect all right all right gorgeous
here hold a little pinky there that's it
cause I get with the Caliph's faces
that's it and guys lean towards me
beautiful and say that we are darling
this mum towards me just you and tilt
you him all this way and then come close
doors with your face sir
so basically what's happening is Aaron's
closer to me so so mom you need to come
closer and you come back darling see you
on the same plane sarin come back that's
it now cause it yep perfect
that's it beautiful and hold the flowers
mum would look with it with your hand
and then bring the flowers lower now
perfect and mum come a touch closer just
you a bit more stop there we go now in
the same level perfect gorgeous
shoulders back mum a little bit
that's better beautiful
and you're laughing over here laughing
at my hand you're looking that way
that's it gorgeous you don't that move
I'll get the three girls together and
mom can you hide your hand so I can't
see it from my perspective if your left
hand behind it back here so I can't see
it
cause I kept though I'd turn your body
into mum but mom your left hand just
bring it behind her but where I can't
see the fingers wrapping the other side
there we go hey don't shove your feet
right in and now kicks together all
girls together that's gorgeous beautiful
lovely ladies very nice I'm just
bringing a hair off your face it a
little bit gorgeous looking at me ladies
very nice big smile for me hold it
[Music]
gorgeous and they're both looking at mom
mom with me beautiful goddess
[Music]
mom can relax don't go out with your
sister hi girls
cuddle up with you tight with no flowers
lower hide the hand I can't see it good
and that cause I got together with your
faces
sounds a bit longer just bet see it and
lean forward kicks together
beautiful ladies very nice holiday for
me hold it
other goods I'm Ren who ice bring your
veil darling of your shoulder just
making consistent no all right beautiful
all right flowers bit la girls but on
the same plate hide your hand darling
but I can't see it that's it lean for
girls
lean forward and quite a get together
with your faces eyes they get perfect
girls very nice beautiful big smile well
next bridesmaids come nice and close
I'm ray the waist sounds real or and ten
your body's this way
now but you lean forward towards me so
they see lean forward lean foot wow got
amazing eyes as well you guys are crazy
top your head who died top you there and
seen your face hélène towards me
pensions up looking at me
chins up girls that's it beautiful
gorgeous
all right cause you get with he faces
but not nice and cuddly come - come -
come - hey gorgeous there we go once
again
before that was Gordon now check the
chick chick the chick there that's it to
make both sample of it so sad its
trailer going this - that's it now and
living how to get perfect hey don't
there we go
I'm your sister you spun around your
sister like the N round big colors and
then class together
that's it everything down and then the
bride now you guys go together cluster
bring your sisters now and your face
really close together
All Right girls that's fine it's perfect
there we go and come back in this side
not covering a little bit time on the
side okay girls
[Music]
giggles giggles giggles giggles because
pod you're handling Aaron on that that's
bit of beauty looking at me girls big
smiles
[Music]
and now Beth look at daddy giggling look
look at that a guy
[Music]
okay ladies and each other's waists I'm
around that's you send your bodies into
each other guys spin the flowers lower
down
that's it hard you're right handling
where I can't see it hit more so there
you go and that lean forward towards me
bring the flowers up a little bit higher
that's it never forget and then cause I
get with your faces oh my god is pick up
a dress if you have to walking in that's
it and then bring it almost right back
in shoulders back that's in a turn your
money that way that's in a lean about
your upper chest see this way yeah
that's it that's it lean forward towards
men shoulders back and I turn your face
extreme right that's good chin that's it
beautiful love that but now your eyes
just bring your eyes a little bit more
inside the room rather than outside
I think Kurt knows better beautiful
that's gorgeous giggling a little bigger
that's it
[Music]
beautiful eyes at me loving me too there
you go
[Music]
all right go just take a sit right on
the edge okay now turn your knees this
way yep
now sit your backside more into the
chair now very gently lay down perfect
you are a knockout that's incredible
unbelievable okay attend
Hey hope you're enjoying the video so
far we still have more to go so don't go
anywhere but I just wanted to pause to
remind you to click on that subscribe
link below so you always stay up to date
when we add new videos and you never
miss out on a thing and if you want more
videos like this make sure you go to
Gianni's calm and sign up for a
subscription so you can access so many
videos just like this 24/7 now back to
the video that's it that was gorgeous
and Isis on my hand is just here hi
gorgeous beautiful love it
[Music]
as a megabit picture
eyes down gorgeous lower lower lower
beautiful
guys amigos
okay ten you first way
beautiful
eyes here and lives together just one
little time is this size
giggling
[Music]
let's not drop darling bring the elbow
closer to you that's it Ben the shoulder
rod up a bit more that's it
gorgeous and the solder up again dolly
gorgeous if you want cause I'm a
gorgeous all right can I have the three
Pink Ladies and front please okay just
grab it and you're gonna hold the
flowers like that with your hands there
and like that perfect now my get your
run over here girls come on in come on
in I'm in and can I have let me see here
can I have you dying I'm at you decide
tell you about that one put your arms on
each other's waists
hey darling have you seen just right
there perfect continue wanting that way
okay now I mean your flower sort of like
in-between here now girls that the
stennis closes you cancer was a little
ones now girls extrapolated you can and
faces as close together as possible come
back a bit that's it and now we're here
we're here we're here we're perfect all
right
after this one girls will go yeah hey
Dulli can you bring your first down
darling
that's gorgeous sweetie gorgeous there
we go beautiful one second there perfect
[Music]
alright girls the next smell got a nice
smile sweet gets no more no more
okay alright everyone's looking at me
girls looking at me there we go just the
big girls looking at me a big smile
now the get the little girls are
giggling at each other and the big girls
are looking at each other go for giggles
come on
all the girls go except for the bride
little one-eyed together - before that's
it now sketch identification that's it
perfect looking at me girls
hold that hide that hand only where I
can see it and bring her hand around you
that's it curls be cuddles gorgeous chin
up food
[Music]
we got you all right done Lamar right
good
I think we're two second I love it but
everyone else go out like I said it and
we'll meet you there till done continue
face away
that's gorgeous hangin a gorgeous it's
worth the trust me
giggling give me a little bit that's it
beautiful now turn your face a complete
profile that's it chin down and eyes
down
now I'm very gently one last shot
promise now I don't need to do very
gently just put your hands out like this
like that and then hands up like that as
well mm-hmm it's really gentle that's
better perfect like that gorgeous about
ten you everybody towards me that's
gorgeous like that beautiful and that's
in your face back that way again yeah
look at me go just tell you face that
way now tilt but yeah that's it that's
in your face left beautiful eyes it make
noise
[Music]
beautiful eyes down perfect let's go go
to the doorway
and then come back out but don't look at
me busy - all in the picture so
basically you're gonna go here then do a
u-turn and just walk out it walks slowly
and do not look at my camera go for it
just something like it's like you're
walking down trying to stretch out there
okay now come forward are you guys stay
where you are
rather just go fuller that's it
something how we dress and come close
towards are there because of just
rewrite to walk and and girls you're
looking into the giggling and you're
looking at that like giggling a little
bit there
[Music]
okay now everyone working up this way
but don't look at me and a bit of action
but a giggling bit of rocking around
hold it guys
I got you yeah let me do last little one
of you just on your right there yes yes
ah there we go
[Music]
oh you can't not take this shot keep
going down just I want to go past this
crap yeah that's a bit too wide so we'll
go here and then we'll do a couple of
vineyard shots alright thank you mate
that's awesome thank you turn left I
think turn that way keep turning keep
turning stop good stop
okay how the flowers just like that
mm-hmm
shoulders back gorgeous
we were just saying how beautiful you
are the car all of us
shoulders back now arch your back lean
forward
don't move chin down eyes here that's it
rise down darling your flowers
so stretch it right out so this it just
bubbles up a little bit yeah bring it
right out as far as you go pull it pull
it pull it that's it
that's better much better okay
and bring up my long lens as well
darling if you can't oh my goodness now
very gently turning your buffer body
towards me a little bit keep it going
keep it going
flowers point towards me now bring your
right toe forward and then bend the knee
in
that's it lean forward now turn your
face this way again that's better
perfect
okay chin up Olivia go to stay that's
beautiful football that's it champ
Morgan beautiful kiddo
[Music]
all right go just pop the veil up with
both hands that's it now put your left
toe towards me bring it right out that's
it bend the knee a little bit more shift
your butt away from me and your chest
forward towards me
that's better perfect this hand stretch
it out and now relax it like this
lalala gorgeous now this hand sort of
bring it around you know that's that's
perfect that's good
Lexx ahead of it more holding with your
right hand as well yeah okay now turn
your body this way so I can see both you
action alert that was good - that's
better perfect now but see how you're
straight so go straight perfectly
straight first and now just relax both
hands perfect upper body towards me and
face out that way gorgeous perfect
gorgeous
[Music]
giggling a little bit hey girl
and now with your hand with the veil
bring overlap the front that's it
beautiful and there bring your hands
down a bit lower perfect you know like
that like that and cross your hands over
that's it beautiful
and now shoulders back a little bit lean
for with your chest turn your face that
way chin down eyes down
[Music]
go about 10 meters that way keep going
keep going keep going keep going about
there okay that's beautiful now turn
around towards me darling and grab the
whole dress and bring it over her left
arm like she's walking with it that's it
look at me going like this perfect and
bend your elbow in a little bit more
this way perfect
now turn you by this way point your toe
towards me in this way lean forward and
turn your face this way now if you can
couple steps this way beautiful now turn
your body that way bit more gorgeous
don't move that's perfect
gorgeous turn your face this way and
chin right up go ahead is that move
[Music]
Yzerman gorgeous beautiful
[Music]
beautiful lovingly big smile gorgeous
yeah Wow
[Music]
what I want you to do very gently is
look at your right hand
pick up there just like your better walk
that's it and pick it up I'll bet bend
your elbow good that's in your face left
that's it lean forward again bend your
elbow up that's gorgeous and you're
laughing at something over there that's
you
now your eyes are at me now
and there will be one shot as you're
walking someplace top top top won't say
you don't walk just just stationary one
more shot
come on this way stop that perfect
that's it beautiful and turn your face
that way little bit don't tilt and eyes
down chin down
[Music]
hey hope you enjoyed that video don't
forget to click the subscribe button
below so you always know when new videos
are added and you're always up to date
and if you're like me and you can't get
enough jump over to Gyoen Escom and sign
up for jerry kione's photography
training where you'll have access to
hundreds and hundreds of hours worth of
educational content plus business and
marketing tips lots of great workshops
and photo sessions from fashion shoots
portrait sessions weddings and so much
more see you there
[Music]